[Music]
when that test hit the ground it was all
over for stop motion
you're saying that is a traditional 2d
morph shot on the 3d render i love how
much character you have packed into this
visual effects shot i also hear that
you worked on the scorpion king shot the
scorpion king shot is that true that's
absolutely you want to take a look at
that today
huge thanks to raycon for sponsoring
today's episode stick around to the end
to see how you can get 15 off your pair
of premium wireless earbuds hey what's
up welcome back to another episode of
visual effects artist react today we are
joined by a very special guest we got
john burton jr on the couch with us
today he is an og island artist here and
tell us a little bit about some of the
stuff you've done well i've been
involved in a lot of really big sort of
visual effects pictures with lots of
creatures that's kind of my speciality
things like the mummy the mummy returns
the men in black men in a black two i
started out doing morphing at ilm
morphing terminator 2 and i've been
working in films ever since i also hear
that
he worked on the scorpion king shot the
scorpion king shot is that true no he
did i work on it but i was the
supervisor on that whole show so
everything that comes out of that movie
eventually i have to take some kind of
responsibility
john so your journey at ilm started with
t2 but how did you get to that point
sort of came from
the idea that i got involved with
computer graphics this was at ohio state
at the ohio state computer graphics
research group we started a flying logo
company back in 1981 called cranston
surrey productions and we did logos for
abc news okay cinemax and stuff like
that i went to germany after that and
helped start a company that later on
wrote middle right really okay yeah
mental ray was my first photo reel
rendering right yeah and it's a great
it's a great ray tracer and so i was
hired on t2 to come in and fill out the
staff of what we called computer
animators in those days okay
and when they brought me in they said so
we've got this crazy program that blends
these images together seamlessly that we
use on willow there's only one guy who
knows how to run it and that's doug
smyther with the program so he taught me
how to use this program and i became
the dude that did morphs oh guys you're
the morph dude i'm the more would you
roll into work every day and be like
it's morphing time oh my god no i'd roll
into work i'd roll into work every day
and i'd see these floating grids you
know of
because it was all there was no spline
based stuff yet i remember there's a
pretty iconic shot in t2 where the
t-1000 hits the wall and like reverses
right right did you do that that was my
shot and it's a shot that i'm really
excited about
i think the thing that works the best
for me and convinces me that this is not
a vfx shot but like a crazy stunt that a
liquid robot is doing is the fact that
his fingers line up so flawlessly i see
the hand silhouettes and it takes me a
moment to realize the hand then mirrors
itself and is able to bend away the
other direction and that's the thing
that makes me go wait a minute he just
reversed that was the artistry of
morphing because they didn't exactly
line up but you've got to make them
exactly line up the idea was to get it
there just at the right time so that as
soon as it gets there his fingers peel
off and you're in motion right away my
understanding of how morphing works is
you warp your image which is just like i
said a basic grid warp and then you
basically do a crossfade between the two
clips of video but they're warped into
position ideally as it happens so you're
doing two distortions you're distorting
the first image into the shape of the
second image and you're distorting the
second image into the shape of the first
image and then you're doing a cross fade
as their distortions converge now what
we're doing here is on a grid point by
grid point basis changing that
relationship as to how much distorted it
is from a to b and when it goes through
that so there's a curve you can control
point by point where the transitions
have so a normal transition would go
from zero to one like this right linear
but what we're doing is we're saying for
the fingers for example maybe they stay
with the a side and then they suddenly
go to the b side
i mean there's the whole like yeah i
gotta warp everything and make it fit
but then there's also like i'm gonna
choose that one to change here and this
one changes here
very moment by moment moving these grids
it's just animation it is totally
100 and you're injecting artistry into
it by choosing when those convergence
points happen that's right he doesn't
just more through himself he kind of
does it artistically he like zips
himself up yeah and so i made the
wrinkles move and i re-timed the pixels
so that rather than just all
transitioning at once like
they transition from the top to the
bottom in time to make it look like he's
got a plan he's kind of like an artist
you know he's like changing in a way
that's like cool it makes it feel like
there's an actual process involved but
he's thinking about functioning you know
he does this he's like yeah you think
you got me you think you threw me
against this wall check this [ __ ] out
he's got a dramatic flare
i love how much character direction you
have packed into this visual effects
shot well that's what i think about when
i'm doing these shots it's not just me
it's everybody working on every shot has
this creative process going on in their
mind right each person working on the
movie has a contribution to make and if
your contribution is at the highest
level of quality that you can bring to
it whether it's animating a character or
setting up a segmentation by hand you're
improving the movie
has chosen you to be her guardian
would you say that willow is essentially
the birthplace of morphs absolutely it
is
next
they're using live-action stuff here
it's all live action there's no cgi in
this it's before cgi is even happening
so this is all using digital compositing
they had never tried to do this before
and so they had to shoot it imagining
how it would work and so what they did
is they built all these puppets and
these intermediary puppets and what they
discovered
was that if you use the intermediary
puppets they're false keyframes they
force you into a time where you hit a
certain mark and it would bump oh
interesting okay they would sort of go
okay transition there's the ostrich
there's the turtle there's the tiger
what they did is they took out the
intermediary steps by running a spline
through it and letting those images just
be what they are in the intermediary
stages you have to line up the grid so
they never look wanky but it made it
smoother it made it smoother it made it
a better transition so even though they
put the effort into making these
in-betweens that they thought they would
need to make it smooth they realized in
hindsight it wasn't necessary and the
shot was better without them because no
one had the experience of trying to do
these kinds of morph transitions to
understand how it worked they tried it
out they found out what the things were
so they didn't make those decisions on
t2 and also those decisions were driven
by the movie that comes in between these
two which is the abyss
[Music]
so the interesting thing about this shop
is that it's a 3d displacement on the
piece of geometry that defines the water
creature and that 3d displacement came
from a scanned model of the face of the
actress so now how do you animate that
and so the way they solved it is they
could do a displacement on the
parametric surface using a displacement
map so
they took the face of the actress the 2d
image and morphed it this you're saying
that is a traditional 2d morph shot on
the 3d render it's a traditional 2d
morph used as a displacement oh
interesting on the surface so the
displacement map itself which is
basically a two-dimensional image you're
morphing that to the other expression
and then you now have an animated
displacement right exactly right oh i
follow i follow absolutely okay okay so
the only reason i bring that up is that
that's problem solving right yeah you
got to figure out how to do it you're
actually using the reality to drive
what's happening rather than being a
part of it it's driving it you have your
spectacle you know your artificiality of
your visual effects right and you need
to bring the complexity of reality into
it you need to drive it with reality to
help make it feel real likewise you have
your reality the things you actually
film with the camera but you need to
bring that spectacle that artificiality
to it to elevate it and make it
something special right the computer
graphics needs complexity because it's
built out of a finite mathematical
system so you borrow complexity from the
real images that you're using in concert
and that gives reality to it likewise
the real thing doesn't meet up to your
expectations because it's not capable of
it so that's the spectacle part and the
live action is borrowing
spectacular imagery from the digital
world the synthetic world and the
synthetic world is borrowing the
complexity of reality from the real
backgrounds together they create a
synthesis which is of course greater
than the sum of its parts
we checked the statistics in zero
percent of you are subscribed to this
channel so you should all subscribe
right now
zero of you come on not even one of you
has subscribed
so you also worked on the second mummy
and we have made a video about a
particular shot in this movie before but
would you want to you know maybe talk
about this one sure it was
a dark day in my life
when i went on the internet google said
hey check this out here's an interesting
thing you might be interested in the
worst visual effects shot in the history
of ever and i'm like
but wait that's the scorpion kink and
i'm like should i watch that video
no
i watched it and i felt bad
i'm so sorry but that wasn't you guys oh
wait you're not talking about our videos
no it was people long before you guys
were okay
we're putting this out together no yeah
see those guys are the guys that
inspired you to do what you did
biggest thing about the scorpion king in
this movie is that we didn't have the
reference that we needed this isn't
really an excuse but it's an explanation
of the way things work in movies
sometimes is that we ask for that of
course we need a day with dwayne johnson
to photograph his face in high detail
and do all the stuff that you would do
because he was busy with his incredible
wwe career that was not possible we had
him for i think three days maybe in
morocco to shoot his scenes so when you
guys did your deep fake you had two
hours of reference that did not exist
yet because the scorpion king came out
after this right of course of course we
use that as training data for the the
deep fake so in our case what we would
have used that for was all of the
reference from three dimensions to be
able to do an understanding of the model
makers to make that face really perfect
we had shaders for subsurface scattering
but they were also relatively
rudimentary but what we didn't have was
the ability to make the kind of textures
that create the kind of structures on
the face you know the pore structures
that you're so famous for pointing out
those are the kinds of things that
didn't make it in i think if you had all
that stuff the animation
would work better because it's meant to
be a little cartoony here and i think
that informed our decisions about
whether or not these shots were done and
ready for the movie was that there was
an expectation at the time of this
needing to reach a certain level the
thing is with this sequence is that
there's a bunch of shots that are not
looking great but there's a bunch of
shots of the looking grip like this
one's brilliant right until actually
comes in there and if you look at the
shots that are less challenging the ones
where you know he's in profile or he's
fighting with somebody or all that kind
of stuff and the focus is not so much on
his face as on his action those seem to
work much better this shot looks great
yeah there's lots of different things
that are going on here you know you were
talking about the wetness of the skin
and all that and you can see it's
actually better in those shots and when
you start getting closer then those
things start to break down into their
component parts it was still in that
same place where the polar express and
these other kinds of movies that were
attempting similar sorts of things were
also struggling with it was all kind of
like the wild west at the time you're
all figuring out how it works let alone
the best way to do it and in this case
it didn't achieve a level of quality
which stood up once you moved into the
future and saw better cgi than this like
planet of the apes and all the other
things that we've now seen that gives us
an expectation of what photo realism is
when you have something like this you
always have to get past the butt
hurtedness of it
and think about what did you learn i
mean i knew we needed reference
but we couldn't get it and i thought
well we can make it anyway i like to say
you know shoot for the moon because if
you miss you land in the scorpio
constellation right
i can't believe that in the span of five
years you went from scorpion king to
davy jones i mean the complexity of
davey jones compared to the scorpion
king is really high the scorpion king
just has to cruise in on his scorpion
body and smash stuff
but i would say you know to this day i
think that the davey jones sequences in
this movie are some of the finest visual
effects ever and i don't think they'll
ever fall out of time you know they're
always going to look great
but i wonder sparrow
can you live with this you do borrow
this idea that you know he is a magical
creature so it's okay if he looks weird
yeah you know and
and you kind of get away with it here
and the scorpion king didn't have that
kind of buffer you know the idea was
that you were trying to get to really
believe it was dwayne johnson and you
know after the fact there was a
discussion well should we have added in
like scales onto his face or some other
sort of crustacean-like thing that would
have i mean would have helped the shop
look better that might have helped you
know like we've talked about the uncanny
valley before and one of the problems
here is that dwayne's face looks too
much like dwayne but it's unable to
fully get there and the reason why davey
jones's face works so well is that it's
not a human face right so automatically
right out of the gate you're not even
trying to think that it's a real face
that's right and so it allows you to
kind of just believe whatever you're
seeing a little bit better yeah and
that's a really important idea to keep
in mind when you're designing these
kinds of visual effects from the top
down you know if you're really working
on the very beginning of a movie it's
like okay what's this effect going to
look like and that's where you get
designers and art directors in there to
help you understand what it's going to
be understanding where to give yourself
help to make sure that you can get over
the bar and then if you get over the bar
then you can start moving in a different
direction this is sort of the story of
jurassic park
jurassic park started out with the idea
that the whole movie was going to be
done with stop motion go motion maybe
some 2d image manipulation to try to get
some motion blur onto the stop most
stuff so then you get this invasive idea
that well we're going to have maybe a
few shots that are going to actually try
to do a cgi dinosaur maybe in the
distance you know maybe if we have a
herd of things maybe do a few shots here
and there just to tiptoe around it
you know that idea set in motion the
tests which ultimately resulted in this
we could do the t-rex stomping around i
was in trouble and when that test hit
the ground it was all over for stop
motion
and that was the end of that
and you know there's a semi-happy ending
to this which is that phil tippett the
master of dinosaur animation amongst
other kinds of animation this was kind
of his his baby right this was his thing
the very first thing that was done after
we were awarded the work to do cg
dinosaurs was to hire phil tippett as
the animation director mm-hmm okay and
now
that was the first thing we did we also
did a lot of work to try to keep it real
not only by hiring stop-motion animators
to work on the film but also to build a
very specific device that was something
that tippett had been working on before
the movie started i think it was called
the dinosaur input device what it was
was an armature wired up to sensors so
that as the stopmo animators were
animating this bare armature it was
recording where the positions of those
armatures were and translating them into
skeletal animation that's a little bit
like motion capture using a puppet
exactly and the idea was that you then
drive a computer graphics model with
that stop-motion animation which allows
you to carry through that pre-existing
expertise of exactly how to move stuff
those are the kinds of things that i
really find interesting and that's where
you know as i said the stop mo animators
come into their own in that regard and
there's lots of creatures that need to
be animated now and you find the people
that have that kind of understanding of
straight ahead animation now have a way
to use that expertise and get it onto
the screen and also
not have to necessarily live with the
limitations of straight ahead animation
so there's this hybridization of the
animation stuff you've had a lot of
wisdom that you've shared with us today
and i really appreciate that so if you
have any ideas for other types of wisdom
that you would like to know of leave a
comment down below
oh man there's so much going on in this
studio constantly it's very hard to find
a place of refuge just to say listen to
a podcast or something formerly this was
the only place where i could actually
get some peace and quiet but courtesy of
today's sponsor raycon i can now get
peace and quiet amongst total and
complete chaos courtesy of their
everyday earbuds i think i'm ready to
re-enter the chaos
recon's everyday earbuds look feel and
sound better than ever and with
optimized gel tips they have the perfect
in-ear fit which is not only going to be
incredibly comfortable and something you
can wear all day but also something that
will not budge or fall out of your ear
during activities work or what have you
and not only that but they offer eight
hours of play time and a 32 hour battery
life with a rechargeable carrying case
conveniently able to fit right in your
pocket or purse but the best part about
raicons is that they come at about half
the price of any other premium wireless
earbud on the market and that not only
saves you money but it keeps you
sounding good and looking good raycons
are also siri and alexa compatible and
they have noise isolation and awareness
mode which allows you under awareness
mode to hear people around you or under
noise isolation mode obviously to
isolate all the noise around you
hey jake
sorry i zoned out there guys if you're
interested in getting a pair of raycons
for yourself go to byraycon.com
corridor crew and you'll get 15 off your
purchase or just click the link in the
description below that's by
quarter crew for 15 off anyway thanks
for watching and uh let's get back to
the video
i'm gonna get back to my podcast
john this has been a huge treat getting
to hear first-hand experiences from all
these movies that i grew up with and
idolized as a kid these were awesome
movies and you just dropping all this
knowledge on us has been a great time
and i really appreciate you doing that
for us so thank you i've had fun too
it's a pleasure to talk about this stuff
to review all the wonderful work that
everybody's doing is absolutely part of
what makes it worth doing it one final
thing john i also i just want to thank
you for all your awesome work you're
helping with these incredible visuals
that have inspired us and many other
people throughout the years well that's
kind of why you do it is to make
something that people can see that that
improves their life it's been a pleasure
working on these films and there's more
on the way certainly had a big impact on
all of us here well we'll see you guys
in the next one
so long consider subscribing